[Music]
look at this world this beautiful world
we built this wall together world our
dreams come true
a world where you can be free
but this world is a lie this world
deserves to die
because this is your world
[Music]
we've lived by your promise Marlena
we can save this world
[Music]
we can burn it to the ground
from the ashes building
[Music]
our world a verybody brand new west
world super bowl trailer so let's bring
it down and probably the biggest easter
egg of all is the viral site that they
just launched that reveals five
additional parks that we haven't seen
yet bringing the grand total to six
[Music]
we've lived by your promise mone
we can save this world
[Music]
we can burn it to the ground
so as you can see in this video when you
mouse over these it just says authorized
personnel only and it kind of reveals
the next part we've gotten to look at
samurai World so that's probably what
this one is but the others tease that
there are many more out there and I'm
guessing that they also have separate
themes like they do during the original
movies so we can all just guess on what
they are like they probably do have a
Roman world they probably do have a
future world but we don't know how
they're integrated in their functions
into this main hub here of West world
like we don't know if this control
facility is just for West world itself
or a forward controlled all of the parks
from this one central location there's
actually a really cool map of it here
you can see it actually goes way further
beneath the ground here the premiere
dates confirm for April 22nd of course
I'll be doing videos just like I did for
season one but if you didn't know
Christopher Nolan's brother Jonathan
Nolan is the person behind the series he
did persons of interest he's done a lot
of TV stuff before Westworld is like his
latest big hit he personally directed in
wrote the Super Bowl teaser that they
released and he said that he intended it
to be kind of a parody on traditional
Super Bowl trailers with a little bit of
footage that we would not see during
season two but he said for the most part
this is all stuff that will show up and
they will do a separate proper trailer
later in the year but obviously if it's
gonna premiere in April when he means
later in the year he's probably just
talking about next month but here I'll
just read his quote from the interview
that he did about this big Superbowl ad
he says the idea behind the 90 second ad
was to emulate and then totally subvert
the typical Americana tropes of the
Super Bowl ads I wanted it to feel like
one of those beautifully crafted love
letters that you get in the Super Bowl
something that gives you a sense for
what the park was supposed to be like
this ideally dream of the idealized West
that Americans got sold during Super
Bowl ads and then pull the rug out from
under and remind the audience what
they're really watching so like the bull
in the china shop just running through
taking all those people out he said
specifically the only footage that will
not appear in season two was the shot
where Dolores turns and addresses the
camera everything else is from season
two episodes but he did say they
embellished some of the footage too so
like when the Bulls running through this
production facility here they probably
slowed it down it's probably not
slow-motion during the episode
specifically he said that they wanted to
use these bowls as a parody of the Bud
they're Clydesdale horses like when you
watch those Budweiser ads from a long
time ago they just running through the
snow so that's why they use this in
conjunction with that Kanye West runaway
song so very on the nose but obviously
there are a lot of familiar faces during
the actual footage particularly
Abernathy who's back I love the way that
they combined his personalities to make
him seem psychotic during season one and
just the idea that he's back now which
version of him are we going to meet is
gonna be the crazy version I should have
such revenge's on you both
but they are yet I know not but they
will be the terrors of the earth they
also teased that they would delve more
into the origin of the parks even though
we got a bit of that as Dolores was
completing the maze once again remember
the big twist at the end of season one
was that she had completed the maze
before achieved consciousness and they
had to roll her software back so she
kept doing that over and over and over
across the years the really big thing
here is that we're actually seeing del
owes the founder of the company that
looks like he's been strung up in the
trailer so this looks like some of the
bloody origins of the park itself the
origins of the delos company as well you
see Dolores and a flashback scene with
Ben Barnes character you also see a lot
of the ghost nation this is a new
character here this could be Maeve
that's dying here there are a couple
scenes with her and her daughter so her
big mission was to find her it sounded
like she had been put into another part
so she maybe tracks her down maybe he
keeps having visions of her in
flashbacks that might be what they
included in the trailer the flashbacks
part of that the part where she keeps
dying and her daughter keeps dying they
did a little bit of that during season
one but then come to find out that it
was the man in black who was pretending
to be those other characters and she was
just remembering it wrong but remember
she's died a thousand times the host can
die as many times as they want and
they'll just reboot their consciousness
in a new body but it looks like there's
a whole bunch of park guests that gets
slaughtered down here on the beach these
actually look like bodies of either the
people that are part of the company or
just regular guests which is general
mayhem and chaos in the wake of journey
and tonight's program being started and
other a lot of theories about the park
itself having this general AI that sort
of controlling things and keeping the
board from knowing that something's bad
so that you have this situation where
all the hosts are becoming aware and
people are trapped in the park with them
so it's become this park of nightmares
but just remember the idea of the five
other separate parks and how they're
gonna delve into that expanding further
on the origin of the parks obviously you
have Maeve who's kind of become a super
host now that she's amped up all of her
natural abilities so I wouldn't be
surprised if they crank up a lot of the
other hosts too like Dolores seems like
she's another one of those super hosts
but like I said for the most part
pretty much everybody's coming back but
he get hyped this is gonna be awesome
everybody just let me know what you
think of this and if there any specific
bonus videos that you guys want me to do
before we get more trailers for this
just let me know in the comments but
what will happen is is because there was
a bunch of other Superbowl stuff that
dropped like that Cloverfield movie from
JJ Abrams and I'm allowed to post my
black panther review tomorrow morning I
think that will probably be next but
I'll try to get through as much stuff as
possible but while you wait for
everything click here to rewatch that
infinity war trailer a billion more
times and click here for the brand new
Star Wars trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight